yuck let's welcome Natalie Spencer
Academy since the Ackerman horridest of
salmon comes off at alert on them some
Scott Hill de las horas noble offense in
return Nobles Blizzard is a literature
or segunda Fulton Gordon Ennis we fought
our own castle ishiguro Sammy Ramona
made storage and somatic variant for
blood that of London under war film or
ahem horikita Eve Adam the Nobel Prize
in Literature 2017 is awarded to the
English writer Kazuo Ishiguro
who in novels of great emotional force
has uncovered the abyss beneath our
illusory sense of connection with the
world Lupino belle du lothario
DeMille de cette a desert near Lake
Yvonne Kazuo Ishiguro he had a woman in
Paris songs first emotion Ella revelry
levena su not a elsewh are something on
the confer donna moonda
the Nobel Prize for Literature this year
as 5,000 zips in vivid and in English
and Swift della Casa del Y Figaro
Fillion da in hominin from starter
emotional and vehicle then up called
also a termite leash and abundant height
meet their belt blows collect hats
[Applause]
[Music]
don't say that if you mix Jane Austen
and Franz Kafka then you have fat silver
saguru in a nutshell but you have to add
a little bit of myself post into the mix
and then you stir but not too much and
then you have his writings at the same
time he's a writer of great integrity it
doesn't look to the side he's developed
an aesthetic universe all his own and he
is someone who has ventured into a lot
of different genres and he's perhaps
most known for the remains of the day
but if you would choose one favorite out
of all of his games which I think all
his books are wonderful they're really
truly exquisite I would say that my
favorite is the Buried giant was
published in two years 2017 I also love
the remains of the day I think it's a
masterpiece it's a true masterpiece
where he mixes comedy of manners with
starts out as a PG woodhouse novel and
ends as something Kafka asked I would
say and that novel as I said it was
published only last year and does it
matter to the Academy that this is a
right ridership that is continuing to
grow and develop
well the Swedish Academy Awards the
prize for a body of work and of course
it has to be more or less current but
that's a word that you can use in all
kinds of different ways and of course
this is a British rider and there has
been criticism in the past of you
awarding European riders and not looking
to other countries but at the same time
because we should grow of course has one
leg in the Japanese culture and has
written about other parts of you where
how do you in the Swedish Academy work
to not miss the riders that are in other
parts of the world than Europe well we
have a wonderful library we have
wonderful people around us were always
on the lookout for new and interesting
writers and we speak quite a few
languages among ourselves and of course
how many languages that we do not speak
but then we can always ask people to
write us a detailed report about that
particular writer we do that all the
time
it's a writer with a lot of pathos and
do you think he has something to say to
a world that is a bit trouble at the
moment
well he is someone who's very interested
in understanding the past but he's not
pristine writer is not out to redeem the
past he is exploring what you have to
forget in order to survive in the first
place as an individual or as a society
[Music]
how do you hope that the world will
receive this choice that you made this
year will make the world happy for me to
just we just choose from what we think
it's an absolutely brilliant novelist
thank you
you